[Música]
inicia la carrera por la candidatura
republicana la exgobernadora de Carolina
del Sur Nikki Haley anunció mediante un
video su postulación a la precandidatura
para las elecciones presidenciales de
enfatizando en su trayectoria política y
denunciando fallas en el gobierno actual
Haley hizo pública su aspiración en la
que se enfrentará con su antiguo jefe
Donald Trump
algunas personas Piensan en Estados
Unidos y ven vulnerabilidad la izquierda
socialista ve una oportunidad para
reescribir la historia china y Rusia
están en la marcha piensan que nos
pueden sabotear
ustedes deberían Saber esto sobre mí yo
no me quedo callada cuando das patadas
duele más y llevas tacones soy Nicky
Haley y me estoy postulando a la
presidencia
en el video la política de 51 años
aseguró que es momento para una una
nueva generación de líderes y criticó la
pérdida de apoyos de su partido en siete
de las últimas ocho elecciones la
republicana se desempeñó como embajadora
de Estados Unidos ante la ONU y es la
primera en anunciar su campaña frente a
Trump quien confirmó en noviembre su
intención de lanzarse a una tercera
candidatura presidencial
Haley hija de inmigrantes indios Se ganó
la reputación en su partido con un
discurso de género y raza de una manera
más creíble que muchos de sus padres y
bajo el mandato de Trump fue una de las
funcionarias más destacadas Nike hale
embajador ante Naciones Unidas ha sido
muy especial para mí ha hecho un trabajo
increíble es una persona fantástica muy
importante pero también es alguien que
lo entiende ha estado Naciones Unidas
desde el principio con nosotros desde el
principio
si ganara la nominación Geli sería la
primera mujer en representar a los
republicanos en las presidenciales sin
embargo tendrá una difícil batalla que
librar ya que la mayoría de las
encuestas no le favorecen